men’s health brand in America.
♪
AINSLEY: TOMORROW THE DHS
SECRETARY HALL AN DEGREE
MAYORKAS WILL TRAVEL TO TEXAS
FOR THE FIRST TIME SINCE MAY TO
MEET WITH THOSE ON THE
FRONTLINES OF THE BORDER CRISIS.
COMES AFTER RECEIVING A SCATHING
LETTER FROM ARIZONA’S ATTORNEY
GENERAL COMMANDING TO KNOW HOW
MANY COVID POSITIVE MIGRANTS
WERE RELEASED INTO HIS STATE
SINCE PRESIDENT BIDEN TOOK
OFFICE.
ALSO RUNNING FOR SENATE MARK
BRNOVICH JOINS US NOW.
>> THANK YOU, AINSLEY FOR HAVING
ME ON THIS MORNING.
AINSLEY: WHAT ARE YOU SEEING TO
THE POINT YOU WROTE THAT
SCATHING LETTER.
>> WHAT WE ARE SEEING IN ARIZONA
IS GOING TO AFFECT THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY.
SEEN RECORD AMOUNT OF FENTANYL
COMING INTO THIS COUNTRY.
RECORD AMOUNT OF PEOPLE
ILLEGALLY CROSSING OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER.
WE KNOW THERE IS A RECORDMENT OF
A GOT-AWAYS.
AND THIS IS NOT ONLY A SEASONAL
PROBLEM.
IT’S A GENERATIONAL PROBLEM,
AINSLEY.
AND IT’S -- THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION ESSENTIALLY
SUBSIDIZING AND INCENTIVIZING
PEOPLE TO COME HERE.
SHAME ON SECRETARY MAYORKAS.
SINCE HE HAS BEEN THE SECRETARY
OF HOMELAND SECURITY, A MILLION
PEOPLE.
A MILLION PEOPLE HAVE ILLEGALLY
CROSSED OUR SOUTHERN BORDER JUST
THIS YEAR IN THE LAST SIX
MONTHS.
THAT’S LIKE THE ENTIRE
POPULATION OF JOE BIDEN’S HOME
STATE OF DELAWARE IN LESS THAN
YEAR.
THIS IS HAVING A DEVASTATING
IMPACT ON OUR COMMUNITY,
AINSLEY.
AINSLEY: WHY DO YOU THINK IS HE
OKAY WITH THE BORDER BEING OPEN?
WHY DO YOU THINK IS HE OKAY WITH
IGNORING THE PROBLEM AND NOT
GOING DOWN THERE TO SEE FOR
HIMSELF?
>> I THINK WHAT WE TEACH OUR
KIDS YOU CAN’T IGNORE A PROBLEM
AND HOPE IT GOES AWAY.
THAT’S PART OF IT SECONDLY, I
THINK IT’S OBVIOUSLY CLEAR THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN HIJACKED BY
THE FAR LEFT OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY THAT WANTS TO RADICALLY
ALTER THIS COUNTRY.
SO, LET’S MAKE NO MISTAKE ABOUT
IT.
OF WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW
IS NOT AN ACCIDENT.
IT’S INTENTIONAL AS TO WHY JOE
BIDEN IS DOING IT, HE MIGHT NOT
EVEN KNOW.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS, THIS
AINSLEY.
CARTEL KELLY AND JOE BIDEN’S
ALLIES IN THE THAT THE HAVE
ENABLED AND EMPOWERED THE
CARTELS AND WE ARE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO SEE MORE VIOLENCE IN
OUR NEIGHBORHOODS.
WE ARE GOING TO CONTINUE TO SEE
THE SPREAD OF COVID BECAUSE OF
THESE NUMBERS AND PEOPLE COMING
COVID POSITIVE AND OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE BEING POLLUTED
BY THE INCREASED IN THE AMOUNT
OF DRUGS.
THE FACT THAT SECRETARY MAYORKAS
IS GOING TO THE BORDER I THINK
THE CARTELS ARE HAPPY BECAUSE
IT’S NOT EVERY DAY THEY GET TO
MEET THEIR HERO.
AINSLEY: YOU HEAR ABOUT FENTANYL
AND CRIME COVID, MANY OF THEM
AREN’T BEING TESTED.
NBC IS REPORTING ALMOST 20% OF
THE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE LET OUT
BY ICE INTO OUR COUNTRY HAVE
COVID.
MARK LEVIN SAID THAT HE THINKS
THAT THE BORDERS ARE OPEN AND
BIDEN IS IGNORING IT BECAUSE HE
WANTS TEXAS AND ARIZONA TO GO
BLUE.
WHAT HAPPENS TO OUR COUNTRY IF
THAT HAPPENS?
>> THIS REALLY ISN’T ABOUT
POLITICS.
I’M A FIRST GENERATION AMERICAN.
BUT THE REASON WHY SOME PEOPLE
WANT TO COME HERE IS BECAUSE WE
HAVE THE RULE OF LAW.
YOU CANNOT HAVE CHAOS.
YOU CANNOT HAVE DISORDER.
YOU CAN’T HAVE AN ADMINISTRATION
SYSTEMATICALLY NOT WILLING TO
ENFORCE THE LAWS.
THAT’S WHY I HAVE THREE LAWSUITS
RIGHT NOW PENDING AGAINST BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION AND THEIR FAILED
BORDER POLICY.
SO THIS IS THIS IS INTENTIONAL
AND RADICALLY CHANGE THIS
COUNTRY.
IT’S AN ATTEMPT TO RADICALLY
CHANGE THIS COUNTRY.
THIS IS ALL PART OF THE FAR
LEFT’S PUSH TO MAKE THIS COUNTRY
SOCIALIST OR EVEN COMMUNIST.
IT’S ALL ABOUT CONCENTRATION OF
POWER IN D.C.
THAT STARTS WITH HAVING A BUNCH
OF PEOPLE COME HERE THE FIRST
THING THEY DO IS BREAK THE LAW
AND GOVERNMENT BENEFITS AND THEN
THEY GET FREE HEALTHCARE, FREE
SUBSIDIZED HOUSING.
THINK ABOUT THIS, AINSLEY.
IT IS THE HEIGHT OF ABSURDITY
THAT YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
CROSSED THE BORDER ILLEGALLY AS
YOU MENTIONED 20% POSITIVE RATE.
THEY ARE GETTING FREE FLIGHTS
ANYWHERE THEY WANT IN THE
COUNTRY AND, YET, HERE IN OTHER
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY OUR KIDS
CAN’T EVEN GO TO SCHOOL.
WE CAN’T EVEN GO TO THE LOCAL
RESTAURANT.
SO THEY ARE SHUTTING DOWN THE
ECONOMY AND THEN LETTING
EVERYONE ELSE GET FREE FLIGHTS
ALL OVER THIS COUNTRY.
IT’S FUNDAMENTALLY UNFAIR TO
AMERICAN TAXPAYERS.